Secretary -- members of
Congress,
distinguished guests good
evening, watching via
stream, at the William Richard
school of law at the
University of Hawaii at -- Peace
Corps volunteers in
Belize, and to other volunteers
around the world.
I'm Ted correct -- it's my
pleasure to welcome you
this evening as we continue a
wonderful five year
correlation to (inaudible) --
before we begin please
take a moment to silence your
cell phones, please
note this event is being live
streamed and recorded
for the library's website,
you're giving permission
to use your question for future
broad cast as in
forever, so please ask your
question clearly and ask
only one question.
And for those of you
that are tweeting
this event we're using the harsh
tag Inouye and
harsh tag Clooney.
He was an lymphian
figure here in
Washington and Hawaii, born in
Honolulu
in R he
graduated
high school after pearl harbor.
He
enlisted in the army --
--
On October 21st 1945
in the war's final
weeks he was severely wounded
and lost his light arm
arm.
He returned home with
a distinguished
bronze star metal and 12 other
metals and citations.
His commitment to bias or
prejudiceship
-- the
future senator Bob Doyle of
Kansas. He graduated
from the effort of Hawaii hi and
became first
represent of hi hi when it
became a state. Three
years later he was elected
senator inspireed by the
young President John F. Kennedy,
including his
younger brother, he serveed for
half a century that
includes the national museum of
Native Americans and
on the Senate of the Watergate
committee, which he
chaired from 2009 to 2012.
He was awarded the
congressional metal of
honor for his military service
-- I was proud to be
in the audience in the White
House. He was awarded
the presidential metal of
freedom, becoming to
receive the both metal of
freedom and metal of honor
honor.
We present the third
in a five year
distinguished series to
commemorate by parttianship,
moral service -- we
congratulate -- President John
F. Kennedy, born 100 years ago
this movement this
was planned in collaboration and
held deer by both
Kennedy and senator Inouye.
As the panels indicate
outside more than 7
7,000 volunteers were trained in
Hawaii between 1962
and 972. This evening our speak
ers were consider the
topic inspireing the sense of
service anti-dealism
and discuss how the ideals
remain relevant today.
The event is made possible by
the Daniel K inuwe
institute. We're happy to
Hispanic widow -- I ask
you to please join us in
recognizeing her.
(APPLAUSE).
I'd like to introduce our panel.
Reed Hastings -- one
of his early memories
according to a drive is giving a
tour of camp David
and noticing that camp David had
golden toilet seats
seats. There were no such Amen
itys in the Peace
Corps where he serve the from
1983 to 85, he taught
mat in a high school where there
was no electricity
at all. But it could be said
that Netflex began
there. He took his GRE exam, he
was militaryied to
Stanford's program in computer
science, he enjoyed a a
very successful business career,
always displaying
the verse tilt and self-reliance
of the Peace Corps.
Heceive ad late fee from a video
store after renting
the movie Apollo 13, he owed $40
and he decideed to
create a new company for people
who wanted to
represents movies for longer
than one day. Knelt
Nick was founded in 1997, ten
years later it started
streaming content via the
Internet, it now has
100 million members in over 90
countries more than
the population than in Germany,
and England --
He's on the board of
many organizations
including the California charter
school association,
Silicon Valley, he was on
the board of Facebook and
Microsoft.
Our other panel is is
the 18th U.S.
secretary of transportation. At
the age to of 8 she
immigrateed from Taiwan to
eyewitness speaking no
English. She graduated from high
school in New York,
then began a remarkable public
career that has
always given inspiration to
others. Two 2001 to 2009
she was the 24th secretary tear
of labor, prior to
that she was the President and C
EO of united way of
America and before that the
department of
transportation. And the director
of transportation
and especially for the countries
in the former
Soviet Union, she was nominated
by George HW Bush.
Under her leadership the Peace
Corps
expanded into Poland Lithuania
-- our conversation
tonight will be moderateed an
Compton, she joined ABC
news in 1973, she's covered 7
presidents, she was
the only broadcast reporter
allowed to remain on air
force when when PresidentBush
was unable to travel
to Washington.
After their conversation we will
allow
some time for questions but
first we'll begin with
the video recorded questions
from Peace Corps
volunteers and University of
Hawaii students and
then microphones available and
take a few questions
from the live audience. Please
help me welcome our
distinguished panel to the stage
.
(APPLAUSE).
Thank you.
Good evening allow has.
During the questioning
tonight, and the
conversation between these two
guests, we're looking
for that thread that goes
between public service and
the idea that the rest of our
collective experiences
lead into that and can
illuminate that, I've known
you since we were both young
girls covering the
Reagan administration, she
brought her spouse
tonight. Senate majority leader
Mitch Mcconel thank
you for coming.
(APPLAUSE).
Secretary, you began
as a banker, and you
-- your first government job was
a White House
fellow, how did you get from in
and then into
cabinet position and what was
the thread that got to
you head the Peace Corps? The
thread is curiosity.
I'm an immigrant to this country
. I didn't
understand so much about America
. So, when I was a
banker, I thought I was involve
ed in a number of
transactions, if it was a
private sector it would be
four people, myself, the banker,
the boreer and most
of the time it was a he, his
lawyer and my lawyer
and we were able to finish a
deal in two hours, but
whenever I did a government deal
there were would be
reames of documents 35 lawyers
on the government's
side and it took like months to
close the deal, so I
was kind of curious, why did
this happen, why the
difference? And so, I heard
about the White House
fellowship program and I applied
but it was out of
the sense of love for this
country, curiosity of how
our government functioned and I
wanted to understand
the larger society here in
America.
And then you had been
a department cabinet
position, how did the Peace
Corps arise out of that,
and I remember what happened in
1919 the year that
you took over the Peace Corps
because I remember
missing missing Christmas about
our four little
children, it was the when Soviet
yet union fell a
apart -- they addressed the
nation and congratulateed
to have the courage to break up
the Soviet Union.
You now have a Peace Corp. There
were no Peace Corp
representatives on the ground in
those countries.
President George A W
bush had a very good
feel for world affairs. So in
the summer of 1991, he
already had a feeling that the
collapse, I think
because he never talked about it
, but he must have
had a sense that the former
Soviet Union was going
to collapse and that the peoples
in the former
Soviet Union would need help
from a people to people
kind of exchange but they'll
require different skill
sets, they will require a more
sophisticated kind of
assistance, and so I was in
California in June of
1991, and he mentioned his
interest in placing me at
Peace Corps, and he said the
people's of the Soviet
Union, this ever came about,
would want, would need
assistance in adjusting to a
more industrializeed and
to join a communeity, the
internal communeity if
anything like that were to
happen. I have to give my
husband some credit -- he wasn't
my husband then --
I was just going out with him,
but he was cute, he
still is, so I discussed it with
him, and he was
very encourageing of my entering
the Peace Corps as
the director.
Reed Hastings, so you
graduate from body
en, you're going to go into the
Marine core, how did
that turn into the Peace Corps
and then into a enter
preneural career?
I wanted to do some
form of service and
the Marine Corps has where you
can do summers at
quantity coand then you get
commissioned as second
lawsuit, then I Lou ten else --
I realizeed that the
system is very well organized
and very impressive
but as a junior person, it's
following orders a lot
and I realizeed that may not be
my sweet spot, so I
was able to petition out of that
and then join the
Peace Corps, where you're sent
to many different
places and make it as you go
along and it develops
your leadership muscle in that
way.
Did you get to pick
where you were going?
No you go to your
local library and look
up
enpsychpedia, like men of the
places in the world
it's a very optimistic people
and I was at a high
school math teacher and had a
Fantus particular
experience.
Reed you live in
California, Silicon
Valley, many of the students
watching in Hawaii from
two locations, so Washington
belt way, seems like a
strange preacher and probably
not at times a very
appealing one, do you think from
your point of view
can you explain how how you view
Washington and whether
a public serves career at this
moment probably
doesn't look that appetizerring
to some people? I
think it looks appetizing to
many people whether
it's for Washington or
Sacramento for us in
California. Some people choose a
life of a is the
tear that is dedicated to public
service decade
after decade, you develop a lot
of skills and
connections and can be more
effective. Other people
like myself dabble in it, two
years in the Peace
Corps then in private sector and
I volunteered for
the Board of Education -- you
became chairman?
That's right but your supporting
the professionals
like the secretary tear that are
dedicating their
liveed so as you realize people
make different
choices and that's okay and you
work together I
think there's a lot of different
opportunityies to
either do I'll call it small
tier of occasion
service that I've done and focus
on the private
sector or long-term in many
different roles like the
secretary tear.
I totally agree with
that and I I think
it's important to have these
different paths into
public service. Federal state,
local levels, I think
our nation benefits when people
have a diverseity of
experience in the private sector
and volunteer
sector and come into the public
sector all of that
is helpful.
The student that's are
watching tonight
from Hawaii should they worry
about being put off if
they see Washington looking
chaotic right now?
Democracy is chaotic and messy.
I teach English to
immigrants from Asia, and they
keep on asking me,
they keep on saying, who is in
charge, and I tell
them there's nobody in charge,
then they say you and
I know each other well enough
you can female who's
in charge in America.  The
dynamic aspects of our
society and the balance of power
between the
different branches of the
federal level, you know
making laws is like making
sausage, democracy is
messy. We have a nation of
people, people talk about
gridlock, our country is made up
of
-- Congress is
made up of senators and
congressmen who represent
where they're from and giving
voice to their people,
the people who they represent --
and sent them there
there, so of course our national
discourse and
dialogue is going to be kind of
chaotic and messy as
well.
Let me ask both of you
how do you express
that to the people, the young
Peace Corps volunteers
that are out there dealing with
-- you have stories
of when you were -- about ways
in which people's
lives were change because you
were there and
secretary for you as well, ways
in which you noted
in your tenure lives changed in
places overseas.
Yeah, absolutely, the
Peace Corp and many
things similar to it are great
experiences to grow a
sense of the world. It's
inevitable if you don't
grow up in the U.S. and don't
get a chance to travel
you have one view of the world,
once you live
outside of the U.S. and you see
how broad it is and
the wonderful nature of people
around the world it's
very powerful experience, so I
felt very connected
to everyone. And again, you know
, times may look
chaotic but they're not that
chaotic compared to
World War II or Civil War or the
13 years before we
had a constitution, so you have
to have some
perspective and you might also
look at it and say in
difficult times is when service
is most needed and
most valuable. So I certainly
would encourage any
young person to be involved and
not think about the
last 20 years as a turn off of
politics.
Were there times with
some of the students
and the residents that you dealt
with that you felt
you were able to make the
connection to help them
better understand America, the
1980's were a
different time but that that
different --
Yeah, but I think you
really do it as a
Peace Corps volunteer by example
, it's not giving
lectures on the separation of
powers or something,
it's living your live in a rural
area and being a
decent person and for them it
breaks down the theory
of what America is to make it
very real and personal
personal. So the Peace Corps has
always been about a
very personal touch, and with
the sent's leadership
around the world I'm sure you
got -- I got one slice
of (inaudible) and --
Reed is so inspireing
when he say -- what
he said about the chaos and to
think about Civil War
War, 13 years before, I didn't
think about that but
that's really true.
So when you ask about
what's really --
what difference we're seeing --
you know, when I was
director of the Peace Corps and
I went to visit all
these Peace Corps volunteers and
speak with them and
there are some who are watching
now, they tell me
and I feel it myself that I
changed because I went
to visit them.
And I -- there's some
volunteers here, I
went to ton graduate, I was
single at the time, it's
like -- they gave me a wedding
dress, it's a Matt
that you wrap around yourselves,
I'm sure the
volunteers understand this --
which were the other
areas? The hospitality of the
local people just
overwhelming, every single piece
Iplace I went the
tremendous out pouring toward
Americans is just so
so impressive and inspireing.
And that personal one
on one with
residents may have a softening
effect if politically
a country is not at war with the
eyewitness, did you
have any instances worrying or
thought to bring
Americans home? We did. The
first responsibility is
to make sure the safety and
security of the
volunteer so we did withdraw
Peace Corps volunteers
from the labor of Pakistan at
the time -- but when I
was Peace Corps director one of
the first things we
did was to have an emergency
plan, it was kind of
sad we had to do this but
because they're spread so
far it took about three days or
even more to gather
them together, and so the world
is changing.
Were you able to
airlift them out? Yes yes yes,
we
had institute ad plan -- to
communicate with the
Peace Corps volunteers faster so
they can be
congregated at one piece for
mediate evacuation if
necessary.
One question we heard
from students and
from some in the Peace Corps as
well, asking how --
whether the Peace Corps
volunteers representing the
eyewitness around the world are
representing the
diverseity of the eyewitness of
women, minorities,
was that an issue at all?
Absolutely. Reed is so
interesting but but yeah,
absolutely. Peace Corps
has a hard time recruiting. I
don't know how but 20
years we had difficulty
recruiting people of color.
I want towed make sure that I
was financially
responsible and the thought of
taking two years off
and not getting paid except for
a very small certify
even was not an option. For a
lot of people in
different communeityiesityies --
I don't think we should be
surprised, it's kind of
difference in the culture
diverseity that we have. But we
have to do a more
better job of making known of
what it's like to be a
Peace Corp volunteer.
Reed, in your
experience, especially when
you come out -- you and the
private sector now, are
there good arguments for young
people to get
involved who might not be
traditional Peace Corps
candidates? Yeah I think it's a
great experience for
somebody who is independent mind
ed and one of the
great things the U.S. government
does is delay any
student loan payments --
Explain that -- many
of our students have
built up debt and if you go into
the Peace Corps
that is deferred. And then the
Peace Corps is doing
a brother job of reentry and
skill development and
things, so it's a remarkable
program because it's
now about 50 years and if you
think about most
programs created, in the last 20
or 30 years, they
get associateed with the
political party and the
Peace Corps has been a very
bipartisanship effort
that has wide support and it's
unique in the last
100 years.
Let me broaden that to
a bigger aspect
both of you have worked and
currently are in the
private sector, what are the
lessons that you from
the private sector learned that
are skill that's you
could take your Peace Corps
volunteers could use and
skills you took or think now you
took with you --
let me start with you Mr.
Hastings, the private
sector skills that could be
employed when you're
overseas in a position represent
ing the United
States like that.
When you're 22 and 23
and you're on your
own in a remote part of the
world you do a lot of
stupid stuff, some works out and
but I look at the
miss adventures like this BP
project, it didn't work
out, but this other one which
was water tanks in
local high school did, so you
got to be relatively
fearless and try things and that
mind set of being
okay with some failure and being
willing to try is
tremendously helpful in the
private sector.
A as a former
secretary tear of labor --
For 8 years right? Yes
.
All 8 years.
All 8 years. The
workforce of the future
is very interesting to me and
very important to the
country. I think what's really
importance now is to
go into the future the workers
of the future have to
be knowledge workers and Reed is
in the area of
technology, technology is
changing so much the way
we live and work and travel,
what's really important
is the road to work that was so
valued in the past
is no longer valuable. Most
valuable is creativity,
inagain knewity and the ability
to think.
The Peace Corps
volunteer experience
that's very helpful. It doesn't
really matter if you
want to -- some people may say I
never worked in the
private sector before how can
this help? Every
employer is working for workers
for the abdominal to
be curious, to learn, to adjust,
be flexible and to
be createtive and resourceful,
and these are skills
that if one can gain are very
helpful in any kind of
job in public, private --
And that of course the
purpose of this
program is to encourage young
people to consider
public service, those are the
kind of skills, the
creativity, the being able to
write and imagine
would be important for public
service job as well.
That's absolutely
right. I mean, pushing
yourself to do things that are
challenging, you know
whether it's banking around --
and whether it's
Peace Corps, I think people
learn the most when
they're in challenging situation
s. And that's what
the -- that's what stimulates
the most learning,
it's continuous learning in our
society today.
We had a question
about public partner
private -- private public
partnership in a time when
government funds are limited,
when Americans want
government to have a smaller
role, they want the
private sector to pick up some
of that, where are
those public private
partnerships important for this
government now, for the country
right now, and for
next generation of leaders
coming along? Well-in
terms of -- this is a very
timely question because
this administration has one of
its top priorities
the infrastructure of our
country and how we need to
rebuild, refurbish, repair the
existing
infrastructure, we do not have
enough money as a
country to be able to address
all of the needs of
the infrastructure through
government funding alone.
And we would not want
to fund direct
government funding all these
different projects
because it would have a impact
on our deficit and
potentially dislocate the
private sector markets as
well. There's plentyity, there's
a lot of private
sector money resource that's ra
available and there's
states and other places
municipalities that prohibit
the private sector from
investing in public
infrastructure, so there must be
a way in which we
can not discriminate against
private sectors and
allow them to participate --
A toll road, a bridge
-- it's an effort by
the federal funding
would probably be about 200
billion and we would
level that because a lot of
times -- if you can get
some government monies, the
government moneys is
kind of like a goodies keeping
feel, and it will
attract and entice other
resources to come in.
So if of the 200
billion there will be
opportunity to pregnant private
sector funding
through innovative ways in ways
you can get the
private sector to come in.
Just today I came from
Atlanta, Georgia to
participate in the opening of I
25, it's a major
artery in Atlanta, Georgia, the
bridge on this I25
on March 30th erupted in a huge
fire that resulted
in a collapse of this section of
the bridge, this is
a major artery in Atlanta and it
messed up traffic.
But through -- it's not a public
partnership but
through the private sector this
project came in
under budget, ahead of schedule
and basically 7
weeks it was able to rebuild
this section of the
bridge, and now Georgia are able
to be on the move
again.
Silicon Valley anxious
to help on public,
private partnership, you're
involvement in education
in the state of California isle
general dare.
Some of the most
exciteing stuff in private
partnerships is things like the
private rocketship
efforts you would never thought
ten years ago that
several private companies were
developing rockets
and doing amazing things and we
have self-driving
cars and over the next five or
ten years trace going
to be a tremendous revolution,
how we all get around
and people's relationship with
cars, all these
different sectors are in the
education side, they're
doing westbound based learning
and what's happening
in the classroom and provide
divideizeed instruction,
so we're seeing the role in
technology and multiple
different sectors where a long
time ago it was
mostly from the government.
Let me ask both of you
before we go to
questions from the audience, a
little bit about
leadership, and there are
students in Hawaii and in
the audience here and able to
see this online, and
there always looking for some
kind of key of what
makes great leadership, and I
wonder he if I can
each of you to talk about risk
of over simplifying
things, leadership -- there are
leadership quality
qualities that apply to public
and private sector
that these students should focus
on.
I would say that
leadership can be learned
learned. When I was younger I
always thought leaders
are born, leadership can be
learned. So I think it's
really important for young
people to practice being
a leader, and they can do so in
a very low risk way
by volunteering with agency or
with a cause they
feel strongly about and they can
learn communication
skills and they can learn all
about leadership skill
skills as well. Having said that
I think a great
quality for leaders to have is a
sense of integrate,
they have to be true to
themselves, that they're
true to those that they serve,
and that there's a
pureness part.
That's a challenge
though, sometimes when
you're own personal integrate is
up against a brick
wall of something that seems to
be testing that,
whole true to it --
There are very few
times when most of us
are put in that situation, I'm
very glad to say, but
when that situation does come I
think it's really
important to know who you are
but you stand for your
own values and be strong enough
to stand up for them
them. Maybe a little too
influenced by Frank under
underwood because she knows
house of cards is coming
back in three weeks.
You may have started
Netflex and online
streaming and all those red
envelopes that used to
come but he's also the godfather
of President under
underwood --
Don't lay that at my
feet. I would say
about leadership it's about
being the best person
you can be. There's two types of
people in the world
world, the people that pick up
the trademark when
they see it lying on the floor
and people that walk
by and if you want to be a
leader you have to be the
first person. That's a great
answer. One more quick
question before we start with
those that have come
in, the idea of success in life
is obviously
everything that students want to
inspire but all of
us want to inspire, but can you
learn from setbacks?
Absolutely -- that's learning
experience -- they're
the hardest you learn the most,
wouldn't you agree?
You said before that you have to
be ready to fail,
and I think the hardest periods
in your life are the
time that's you have -- you will
experience the
greatest personal growth. And so
I think for those,
for those that are thinking this
, all of us
encounter adultyies in life and
we have to have the
strength to be able to prevail
and have confidence
in ourselves and also know that
this is the time
when we are really being tested
and being made, our
character and who we are. It's
hard though. It's
very hard. If I didn't have to
do it I wouldn't do
it, but those times when you
have the most difficult
difficultyies that's when I
learned the most.
I think probably 95%
of people never heard
of quickster but your company
had what some called a
desk spiral and look at you now
was that the learn
learning -- the key learning
experience for you?
Yeah, that was a major
experience about six years
ago, Netflex was splitting the D
VD and streaming
business and we made a big
mistake and the customers
went from loving us to hateing
us very quickly and it
took many years to earn back the
trust, and out of
that, we really learn ad lot
about listening to the
customers, if we saw something
that was a long-term
strategy, it is just going a
little bit slower and
bringing customers along with us
, and I realizeed I
could never do elector politics,
don't have the ear
for it, I'm built for business
and I encourage
people to think about what
they're good at. For
myself, I realize I'm good at
business so I'm happy
paying my taxes and volunteering
and being very
thankful for the service among
us.
When you make a
mistake apologize is that
a good business strategy?
Generally, yeah. I would
say to be Frank, customers don't
care that much,
they want the thing fixed. The
apology is okay, but
if you think the apology itself
is going to make a
big difference, there's deeper
issues.
I'm Asian American, I
always apologies.
Ladies and gentlemen, let's take
a few questions and
I'm going to start with a Peace
Corps volunteer -- a
question for Reed lastings,
let's go to the question
--
Hi -- I'm a Peace Corps
volunteer -- I
worked in education sector and
my question today is
for Reed Hastings -- in a world
where the gap
between the rich and the poor is
rapidly widening
every day what do you think some
of the way that's
service work can be useful in
helping privilegeed
people in the developed world
better understand
their piers --
In a worldwide basis
equality has declineed
in the last 30 years, we have
hello on a fewer on a
global basis -- on all of the
internal work that
everyone is doing but to get to
the question which
is how do you create more
empathy and awareness some
is to through entertainment,
some of our shows
about
elite and very insightful,
another of our show
orange is the new black, it's a
sector of the
population that very people have
exposure to women
in prison, so often
entertainment opens people heart
hearts and gets them to connect
to what we're doing.
We have a question
from the effort of
Hawaii, for secretary -- victory
--
Victoria.
We have that question --
I'm a 89 your at the
University of Hawaii
my question as a first Asian
American woman and
former director of Peace Corps a
what is the one
inspirational thing you would
like to share with
minorities looking to share
others? Have confidence
in yourself, don't be afraid,
explore. When I was
growing up I knew so little
about mainstream America
America. But I had wonderful
parents, a wonderful
family, and they viewed within
me a tremendous gift,
as I mentioned earlier it's the
gift of curiosity.
My parents sacrificed so much to
bring us to America
America, and even though they
could not envision
what futures lie ahead of their
six daughters, they
were confident that this country
would offer them
opportunities that they cannot
imagine but they knew
existed.
You were the eldest of
six daughters.
Yeah.
Does the eldest have a
special
responsibility? Of course, Asian
American families
I'm the one in charge and I take
care of everybody
-- I don't think all my sisters
sisters would agree I'm the
one in charge.
We'll do one more
question from the
University of Hawaii, the
question comes from a
student -- my name is Tyler, I'm
a senior the at the
University of Hawaii -- how does
your experience
abroad the Peace Corps attribute
to your success --
The experience abroad
has helped me
tremendously in terms of empathy
and connecting with
people you didn't grow up with,
and with
communications it's trying to
get out of your own
skin and understand how a
message might be receiveed
as opposeed to opposeed to what
you're saying, and so you get a
lot of practice with that being
a high school math
teacher in a rule land --
I would like to open
up the floor to
questions from the audience here
in Washington as
well. I see a couple of hands
going up, two or three
over here and we have microphone
s coming down --
good evening, thank you for
joining us and speak up.
I have a short we for
the savings account
and for Mr. Hastings, you
mention the public/private
partnerships would you be open
to -- do you see
there being I guess some two or
three skill thaws
took from being that match
teacher that you say you
use every day in your current
work? I didn't hear
the question -- would I be open
it what? Long
distance passenger trailtrains
and the like.
I think that would be
very interesting to
explore.
Thank you.
The skills I think
what you learn in
teaching is classroom management
, public speaking,
some of those skills are the
most useful.
Public speaking, get
that student -- I
don't see a microphone -- please
go find someone
over here and we'll get a
microphone to the next
question over here.
Hi, thank you for come
ing to speak. My
question is about if you think
there is a trend in
public service towards or for
the privileged and to
get some caught, we see on
capitol many internships
they don't offer a some type pen
and within the
federal government if you try to
apply for the
internship, they don't offer any
kind of assistance,
so my question is you mentioned
in the Peace Corps
there are barriers because some
people cannot work
for free, especially full-time
hours what are your
thoughts on this and how can we
fix it, public
service is very important but
there are -- economic
barriers and it sounds like
we've given people the
vehicle and the keys but there's
no actual gas in
the car to do public service.
Practical question --
I'm not so negative
-- I think this country has
incredible opportunities
opportunities. And what I
encourage in young people
and in parents is to believe in
the goodness of this
country and be resourceful and
find different ways
to have different experiences. I
think there are
very few people like myself who
came to the country
with very, very little but I was
armed with the most
wealthy of assets and that is a
sense of who I am
and I was also fortified by the
love of my family.
With those two tremendous
treasuryies, that gave me
the courage to go out and
explore and do all sorts
of things. I was on scholarship
during my years in
College and then as my family
situation got berry
gave the scholarship back and
now my family
establishes scholarships for
others. I would say the
most important thing to say is
never give up,
there's so many companies in
this country -- when I
was heads of theiteed way, I
never felt I was taking
-- I give them opportunity to
participate on the
ground floor bigger than
themselves and more
important than themselves.
There's so many generous
benefactors that want to help
and there's many ways
to connect those in need with
those that want to
give and that's part of the
function of the social
sector, the volunteer sector so
I really encourage
people number one, do not be
afraid. Because when I
first came to America -- if I
can say to the young
person it is don't be afraid.
There's so many people
that want to be of help. Find
what you love to do
and go out and help other that's
can help to make
that happen.
Can you add to that
Reed -- how do you go
find the resources.
I don't have anything
to add to that one.
We have a fiberglass
moneymicrophone right
here -- can you stand -- thank
you.
Hi, thank you for
talking -- I would like
to ask how do you make Peace
Corps relevant in view
of
(inaudible) --
I believe the acting
Peace Corps director
is here. I hope to see her, the
Peace Corps is in so
many different countries -- yeah
, you should get up
and answer this question.
(APPLAUSE).
Peace Corps is involveed in so
many
different countries, Peace Corps
volunteers who
understand other cultures,
understand America can be
great bridges of understanding
an increasing
complicated international world.
Find her afterwards
afterwards. We have another
microphone -- please
stand --
Hi my name is Liz and
I was inspireed by my
Peace Corps services in Africa
-- and they are so
proud of (inaudible) they're
inspireed by Americans
but they love their country, and
I would be so honor
honored to get your advice to
that as they try to
create a cultural service in our
country.
Thank you.
Are you asking for advice? I
think what you're doing is great
-- one of the
impacts of what the Peace Corps
is is change of the
volume tires so when they come
back to the U.S.
they're's all of these kind of
efforts so it's great
great. Thank you.
We have a microphone
over here and then I
promise I'll get it down here to
you.
My name is chicken --
I'm very proud of
you to serve our country for so
many years,
I
brought my daughter to get
inspireed.
I came to the country
22 years ago and I
went to leadership program in
Maryland and I found
very few immigrants at that time
-- to be in those
leadership programs and offer to
do public service,
and I still find mist -- right
now I run a small
business but encourage commune
ity to contribute in
social and political activity in
the eyewitness to
be 100% American but I found
myself very challengeing
to change the mental I'll of
people like me to be
fully participating in the
society because maybe my
language or culture is not fully
adapted to the
country, so what is your
suggestion to the first
generation Americans like myself
to be able to fully
participate in the American life
? Thank you.
You know I understand
there are -- when
you're first generation, I'm
first generation, you
worry about survival, you just
want to have
financial security. So for a lot
of these first
generation their first priority
is to be able to
financially secure and take care
of their families.
I am confident as their
financial situation gets
better they will become more and
more integrated and
take a larger role in mainstream
America.
I think as their
children of become better
assimilateed that they take a
larger and larger role.
So I split. You for your effort.
I want to continue
because I think it's important
and I have faith and
hope that as people get more
financially secure they
are turning out, but in the
meantime I ask them to
get involved in their local
communeity. My parents,
my mother didn't speak English,
they were very
active in the Chinese/American
communeity and I
thought that was important as
well.
Thank you for that
question. We have one
over --
Hello, I have a
question for the
significant, you mentioned that
when you were head
of the Peace Corps you wanted to
bring the diverseity
of America into the corporate
such as recruiting
people from different
ethnicities perhaps from
different economic statuses as
well, what about the
diverseity of age, littleian
Carter was famous for
going to India when she was in
her late 60's, how
common is that and this lifelong
learning but
there's lifelong teaching and
many of our
mature old
older people do have the time to
volunteer for the
Peace Corps.
I think we have a new
volunteer.
I think that's a great
observation, and I
think Peace Corps and again the
acting director is
here, Peace Corps has always had
a certainly package
of more mature citizens but I
will point out that
Peace Corps volunteers work in
very, very difficult
positions. And so, some of these
localityies of
someone who is more mature
begins more importance.
And the remote areas are--
sometimes the access to
healthcare facilities could be a
factor in the
recruiting more of mature
Americans.
I don't know what the
occurrence numbers
are, I suspect during your
tenure it's --
During the tenure the
number of
retire es
or seniors was a small
percentage -- it was about 10
10% -- can I say something --
A couple of points on the
diverseity I want
it point out we have made
amazing strides in
representing the face of America
and 36% of our
applicants are represent diverse
in what we call our
on board strength meaning
volunteer in the field is
about 28%, from 14% since 2010,
we have good
strategies and it's working. In
terms of age diverse
diversity which we recognize as
a need it's only
about 7% of 50 produce but we
have a program for
Peace Corps response where a
short term projected
base assignment that's are sort
of tailorsed to
people with experience and
generally those are older
folks so we're very open and
welcomeing to people who
are 50 plusLet me ask you two
quick follow-ups, when
you talk about a short tell me
targeted program that
might be very, very attractive
to somebody who is
just about to refrom work force
but doesn't want to
sit home, are you talking two or
three weeks, five
or six months or does each
project have a different
character? 3, 6, 9, 12 months, I
want to point out
that I think our oldest
volunteer just left she's 85
years old.
My oldest volunteer now is 80,
and that's
send ago powerful message to our
partners in the
field that you're never too old
or young to serve.
May I ask you one
other question which has
come in from from a Hawaii
students asking how can
you -- what can you say to
minorities and non-
non-traditional volunteers to
encourage them to go
ahead and explore the
possibility of a Peace Corps
service?
So the first time I
would say is talk to a
recruiter and they're around the
United States. But
I think in the past Peace Corps
would be viewed that
you did after College to get
away and to have a
great experience but you were
really putting your
career on hold. I think Peace
Corps now is a career
accelerator, it always has been
but we really sort
of in the 21 century with the
Internet and all the
different projects there's
incredible benefits in
terms of leadership development,
flexibility, all
the things that were mentioned
and we have benefits.
We have a scholarship program
that piece corporate
volunteers can
apply to and adjustment
allowance to
help them get started when they
re-enter the United
States. So we have a lot of
benefits that would
serve them. Thank you very much.
(APPLAUSE).
I think we have time
for one more question
from the audience -- you've been
very patient
waiting.
Thank you so much.
President of national
Peace Corps association and I
serveed in the Peace
Corps from 88 to
91, secretary tear thank you
for
your serves in the Peace Corps
and elsewhere and you
are very inspireing and this is
an evening for
inspiration for service. Thank
you for the great
recruitment that the Peace Corps
has now -- over 20
20,000 that are applying to
serve in the Peace Corps
but with funding for only 7,000
volunteers, thousand
thousands of individuals, young
global citizens
don't have the opportunity, what
can we do about
that and the question is for
either of you, how can
we ensure the Americans have the
opportunity to
serve?
I think what's been
amazing about the
Peace Corps, the number is from
2500 to 5,000 down
to 4 -- it's up to 7 now and
over 50 years a stable
program, and you wouldn't want
to grow it too
quickly, you might see a whole
number of effects of
that and on balance, it's been a
by partisan support
support, the founding has been
reliable compareed to
many federal programs, I think
we should be positive
about what we got in the Peace
Corps for the budge.
Can I go back to the
question one of the
previous -- I think it's also
important -- speaking
from an Asian person perspective
, I think it's
importance that we help our
parents and I say this
to young people, the parents may
not understand what
Peace Corps is all about, so for
the young people
who at least in the Asian/
American communeity you
have to try to convince your
parents that this is a
good path forward. So I would
encourage young people
to explain what Peace Corps is,
to make a decision
to build around them so they
understand and will
support that decision.
As a moderator I'm
going to take the
opportunity not ask the last
question -- we have one
more videotapeed question from a
Peace Corps
volunteer who is in Guatemala
and let me introduce
Susan Gonzalez.
Hello -- I'm a Peace
Corps volunteer
working on youth development. My
question is for
both -- how do we make
opportunityies to serve in
organizes such as a Peace Corps
more accessible for
those that come from
disadvantageed communeityies?
We have touched on
this but let me give
you both a chance to sum up your
thoughts. I love
the fact that she's on a rooftop
-- with a dog
barking and a true Peace Corps
experience. If you
could sum up how you think the
skills that you have
been able to learn from not only
the leadership but
in business would translate into
bringing some of
those less tray decisional
volunteers into --
starting with you -- I think
Reed needs to answer
this because he's so
extraordinary successful and
people don't think of the
transition from Peace
Corps into the business sector
so I think you would
have a lot of encouragement to
offer.
In answersing the
Peace Corps in the least
ten or 15 years has made a big
effort in
diversifying, finding great role
models where it's
not just white men and white
women talking about how
great the Peace Corps was
because people follow the
role models that they see. So as
we have more
volunteers like Susan, I think
it's natural that
it's spreading I think it's a
really big success.
Last thing -- life
skills that Peace Corps
volunteers learn is very helpful
and applicable to
all aspects in life and also any
chosen occupational
career, the quality, flexibility
, curiosity and
being resourceful, these Peace
Corps volunteers are
thrown into pretty interesting
and unexpected
circumstances and situations,
and they have to learn
how to adjust and be problem
solveers.
We're going to get you
back as a second
term. You have such passion for
it.
I'll go back as a
Peace Corps volunteer.
Thank you for the Internet world
we live in a world
where we all think we know much
more about the world
that we used to but there's
nothing like boots on
the ground and living within
another culture to not
only appreciate what they are
going through but what
the United States has in terms
of values, standards,
business practices and human to
human contact that
really makes it exceptional.
Thank you so much.
And thank you all for
joining us.
(APPLAUSE)
thank you all so much. What a
wonderful panel. We're grateful
for today. They came
a long way to be here tonight
and we're thankful to
an.
We're thankful for the
institute and the
students in Hawaii on the two
campuses and the many
Peace Corps volunteers around
the world, we can't
see all of you but we feel your
enthusiasm. We'll be
putting forth two more programs
over the next two